I'll play it again.
It's a sound effect called an
orchestra hit.
Bruno Mars, he's the king
of nostalgia and he used that effect in
"Finesse" to take you back to the 80's.
Take a listen to any pop, dance, or hip hop
song in the 80's or 90's and you're gonna
hear a version of it.
There are all types of orchestral hits.
But the original one, this one here.
Isn't from a few decades ago. In fact it was
first played in 1910 at the Paris Opera.
We can thankfully hear
the greatest
composer of our time, Stravinsky, performing
his own works.
Telling us all those
subtleties of his musical wishes and
intentions, which could never be fully
documented in the cold black print of a
score.
This is the famed 20th century Russian
composer Igor Stravinsky. He's about 80
years old here, but when he first
composed the Firebird Suite he was...
28 years old. Holy sh*t.
And during his adult life the
world changed dramatically, two or three
times.
That's Robert Fink, he wrote a
history of that sound you just heard.
Firebird is his first major successful
piece it made his reputation. Everybody
loved the Firebird. Stravinsky is like
one of those rock stars who has one huge
hit early on in their career and then
they have to play that song every
concert for the rest of their lives.
He adjusted the score a bit over the
years but the jarring opener of one of
the last scenes in the ballet remained
one of Firebird's most dramatic moments.
Right, because what it is is it's
basically a gesture for the orchestra.
It shocks the hell out of you, in
the context of the original piece.
So how
did that --
become so ubiquitous that in
1992, NWA said this about it on
Straight Out of Compton?
To figure that
out you have to go to Australia.
I'm Peter Vogel, I developed the first
commercial sampling synthesizer which
was the Fairlight CMI back in about 1975.
The other person who was involved was
Kim Ryrie.
This is the Fairlight CMI. To put it
simply it's one of the most influential
musical innovations of the past 100
years. It was one of the very first
digital synthesizers, a digital audio
workstation, and the first digital sampler
all in one.
With the aid of computers, you
could create the music that you had in
your head a lot more easily than if you
had to sit down and learn to play
instruments from scratch.
It was really a
lazy shortcut.
You got to see this
unbelievable machine, I don't even know if we can
get a camera back here?
Or do we have a camera?
Oh he's back here already. Forgive me.
This is showing one of the sounds, what the pattern looks like.
Do me a favor: punch up let's see how the
sales are in Omaha.
The two major things
that it introduced to music production
were visual sequencing and digital
sampling.
It was the first instrument
that had a screen based sequencer, that
allowed you to actually compose complex
pieces of music, have the machine play it
for you.
It was called Page R.
Here's Herbie Hancock demonstrating it
for Quincy Jones.
And there's two ways to do it:
you can either write it on the screen
or you can play it on a keyboard. Oh okay.
See, now if you write it on a screen...
This is a tool that anyone
today can take advantage of. Hell, I can
sequence a drum pattern on my iPhone.
In the early 80's sequencing like this was a
revelation.
There is a way in which the
Fairlight's interface is incredibly far
ahead of its time.
I mean it's like a
Star Trek thing, right? You're using a
light pen to write on a cathode ray tube.
Do something with a light pen.
Well the world is going crazy ladies and gentlemen.
Many of the musicians who used
it sort of became the Fairlight's
ambassador.
Stevie Wonder was the first
person I delivered one to in the United States
and then people in the studio
would gather around and they said hey I
know someone would be really interested
to see this.
Next thing you know he's in London setting one up
for Peter Gabriel.
He introduced me to
Kate Bush, there were some guys from Led
Zeppelin there.
What really made the
Fairlight a game-changer, though, was the
digital sampler.
You could hook up a
microphone to the Fairlight, record any
second of sound, and then play it at any
pitch on the keyboard.
The Fairlight also
came with a stock library of sounds too,
on giant 8-inch floppy disks.
So we started off with maybe one floppy disk
with 50 different sounds on it.
People who were using it would send us back
floppies and say hey look at these
samples I've created.
While working
on the basic song ideas, Gabriel was also
compiling a library of sounds which he
might use on the album.
For this he used
a computerized instrument called a Fairlight.
Peter Gabriel actually broke the glass
and Kate Bush used it in her music.
There were baby screeches, smashes, drips,
and rotary dials.
And then there was the
orchestra hit.
Ironically the the orchestra hit was a
complete accident which was sampled by
me.
I just happened to have a vinyl
recording of the Stravinsky Firebird Suite
nearby when I was messing around.
That Orchestra hit, which I think was
right at the beginning of one of the
tracks.
And I thought alright it's a good sound.
Peter called the sound orch2 and put it on an
eight inch floppy disk full of those
other stock sounds.
Planet Rock
was the first smash hit record to use orch2. In the first two seconds of the song
it's used five times.
So the thing that
you can know immediately about Planet Rock
is that 50,000 people copied it.
That 8-bit Orchestra hit started popping
up in all sorts of songs.
Within a few years of the Fairlight
being around, all sorts of synths and
samplers came with a stock variation of
the orch2 hit. And they got crisper and
cleaner with new technology.
You can hear that transformation in the
hit Swedish producer Max Martin made
with Britney Spears and the Backstreet Boys.
But that original orch2 sample, it
remains the most iconic. And it's
probably why Bruno Mars used it,
or at least a very close simulation of it, in Finesse.
When you hear that orchestra hit,
you're hearing something which is very
much about the middle 1980's. It's
actually something that was first
thought of by a guy in 1909.
It's like a moment where a whole bunch of times are
sewn together.
It is kind of timeless.
That is the actual piece of vinyl that
orch2 was sampled off.
So you can tell it was a long time ago when you paid, $6.99
for a record.
So there are three links
that are in the description below, one to
Robert Fink's paper,
another to a Fairlight CMI iPhone app which Peter Vogel
helped create,
Last but not least I made
an orchestra hit playlist on Spotify.
Enjoy it.